well wait wait a minute it's not yours
do you think do you think men should
ever say an abortion
like
i'm gonna be real no no i'm gonna be
real no because it's not your body i
would then say
if men can't have a say in abortion
which i kind of likely agree with then
men should be able to opt out of
fatherhood responsibility in the eyes of
the law
you agree with that i do agree with that
if a man didn't want to become a father
and oh it's real
so for example so here's the thing no no
wait so here's the thing right here's
the thing right i knock you up you get
pregnant i don't want the kid you want
the kid right
i am saying i should be able to go you
know what i want nothing to that kid and
you cannot legally take me to court for
any child support for any help
whatsoever right i have the option to
opt out of fatherhood do you agree with
that
i do and i think like that's it if if i
came to you and i went hey look
um if you do xyz i'm gonna get pregnant
and you went ahead with it no but then
there's still that's still technically
on me to be like if you went oh okay
i'm gonna [ __ ] you anyway and then i'd
be like well no amy like you need to
we do all need to prioritize our own
self-interest so i'm personally like
i'm quite responsible in the i'm like
you know what it's on me i'm i'm not
gonna drag anyone i'm not gonna like
it's on me to deal with my own [ __ ]
so i would personally be like yeah like
and especially when that's why a lot of
people choose single parenthood um
if someone gets you pregnant not
particularly though like because you can
go after a man's financial like i mean
girls are trying yeah they're trying to
get you they're trying to get a kid
i think they're trying to
i do think that's the minority that are
trying to like trap a man i'll be honest
i've had
two women in my life which i guess isn't
a lot but i've had two women try and
trap me before
and if they got pregnant by me i
wouldn't be able to opt out of
fatherhood or response i mean i wouldn't
anyway but i'm just saying like i what
i'm trying to say is it
not that it happens a lot
like i'll be honest like yeah i'm an
actor like i'm doing well but i'm not a
superstar by any means but purely
because of where they perceive and what
i can do and they were older as well
they were like
well i know that if i trap this guy like
i i know he'll he can provide for me do
you know what i mean
and i'll be honest that is actually a
really big reason why
i've been more selective
with who i get myself involved in
because i feel like i'm getting to that
point where the age of women that i'm
dating now
that's within the realm of their
consciousness
does that make sense it's so it's so
crazy like if you're saying that yeah
especially if you're dating older women
and to a point where they're like i need
security
i don't
so i'm not sure if you answered the
question do you think that's fair though
like so if a woman can't get oh no i
don't i don't think it's fair so i don't
know i'm saying like do you think they
should legally he could say like let's
say he he gets you pregnant
he he can legally say look i want her to
get an abortion she has the choice to
get it she's not getting it no i want to
opt out of the financial responsibility
i know i think it's all on the woman i'm
like you you're seriously you agree you
agree yeah you're a grown woman at that
point that if you want the kid or you
don't want the kid respectfully [ __ ]
what the guy thinks and i know that oh
he's half of like there's a lot of
things that come into it but i'm but
that's like yeah i'm asking about the
money part you're okay so like he he
pays nothing oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
if i get pregnant and a man is like i
don't want anything to do this kid i'm
not gonna go back and be like oh well
you didn't wrap up you didn't i'll be
like no this is on me this is my
decision i'm gonna own it and you i
would not no no i'd be like okay as far
as i'm aware my kid doesn't have a dad
as far as i'm aware i i am the one
parent that's that's my personal like
thing yeah yeah i wouldn't do it and i i
personally think that women that do that
i'm like
um i i think it's more selfish to be
like well you want this kid this is this
is your
this is how your life is but no i'm
personally like if a guy got me pregnant
and was like i don't know so we agree
there yeah yeah something we agree 100
i'd be like i'd be like like you've got
to own your own [ __ ] at the end of
the day because yeah the only person you
ever have 100 in your life is yourself
so you've got to own your [ __ ]
you've got to back your boss but then
you've got like we're not all victims
we're not yeah and so it's like so yeah
so you agree that it's it's the majority
the woman's fault if you get pregnant
like it's it's your own fault i think i
think fault is the wrong word i would
use but in terms of responsibility
responsibility responsibility of choice
responsibility of choice so it's your
fault no no because fault has got
negative connotations
so responsibility to your choice it's
your body and so if you were like let's
say you're in a loving relationship yeah
and you get pregnant and the guy's like
well i really want to be a dad at that
and you really don't want to carry a
baby to term you really don't want to
lose your job you don't do this you then
have to decide and if he's like if if
he's like
well i'll leave you and i'll be full
betrayed you then have to decide okay do
i care more about him and our
relationship or do i care more about
myself and it's like
we have got
we've got autonomy we've got choice
we've got responsibility and i think
that we need to stop pretending that
women are like pathetic or need a man or
xyz it's like no baby back yourself
we do need men though we do we don't
need them because they do no because
they're lesbians who do who do you call
to get your car fixed a man or a woman
your toilet breaks down who do you call
so i i fix my own car i can i can do i'm
most mechanics your power your power
supply who runs it who runs the
infrastructure of society men or women
oh at the moment obviously
because of patriarchy
wait wait do i need a man no this is i'm
obsessed with being a woman in a
male-dominated industry i do all of my
own carpentry
right but but regardless of that like
you agree that men run the
infrastructure so therefore at the
moment yeah men run the world so they we
need men
yeah yeah on a wider scale yes a wider
scale on a personal scale no because you
don't need a man to provide for you
but we need men to run the industries
that keep us alive and well not
necessarily no so because i know female
mechanics engineers right
remember remember that's exception like
those industries are like 99 male yeah
but for now right so now do you and we
can change that
but do we do it but do we want to change
that some women do something how do you
know the difference between women
picking the industries they want to pick
and
trying to [ __ ] the patriarchy no no i'm
saying like like
how do you know the difference between
women picking the industries they want
to pick
so like i don't know a lot of girls that
want to be plumbers mechanics engineers
and all that stuff
right but you're the exception you're
not the rule i don't know how many
that's what i'm saying
so when you say things like it's because
i'm so valid but you're still valid but
i'm saying when you say things like
because of the patriarchy that's why
women are in those fields how do you
know it's the patriarchy and not women
choosing what they want to choose we
don't and that's not my business right
not my business i know but like why do
you automatically assume patriarchy i
don't know automatically assume it but
that's why we need men because of the
patriarchy right because they are the
ones who at the moment control most of
the world that's why we need how do you
know women don't control most of the
world because they don't pick the
industries where they're like in control
it's not michael white it's right that's
like gray area
right right but i'm saying like could it
possibly just be like i don't think
there's anything stopping women from
getting a job today i don't think we
have anything i think it's easier for
women than men yeah like and then yeah
that's it again it depends what industry
it depends what like i think this whole
like the concept of sleeping away to the
top
women will get more
then it's like oh she was and it's like
well actually we're not then saying
you didn't respect a woman's capability
qualifications and you know you actually
disrespected her and were like you're
only valuable for your sexual like well
i think i think it's because like women
do that